If you are new to Cloud Code, do not watch another tutorial
until you do this one thing first.
And Droppic has released a GitHub repository
and they are the company behind Cloud Code.
This repository includes skills, cookbooks,
prompt engineering guides, full courses,
quick start resources, and even the source code
for Cloud Code itself.
Many people spend time scrolling through content,
installing random skills, and becoming overwhelmed.
A more effective approach is to use this repository
as a foundation.
You can bring it into Cloud Code and use it
to explore the basics, learn structured workflows,
and build a strong starting point.
This allows you to work from a reliable source,
rather than relying on trial and error.
If anyone understands how to use Cloud Code effectively,
it is the team that created it.
You can find the repository link
and a starter workflow in the caption.
DM's send, and I'll send you the link.